You know, it's true.
When something exceeds your ability to understand how it works,...
...it, sort of, becomes magical.
And that's exactly what the iPad is.
It's hard to see how something so simple, so thin and so light...
...could possibly be so capable.
The iPhone was a revolution.
And we learned so much from it.
And developed so many amazing technologies, all the applications,...
...the multi-touch user interface.
It was truly an incredible breakthrough product.
We wanted to take all of that...
...and apply that to a whole new class of product.
The iPad is the best web surfing experience.
The best e-mail experience.
The best photo and movie watching experience.
It's gonna change the way we do the things we do every day.
The face of the product is pretty much defined by a single piece of multi touch glass.
And that's it.
There's no pointing device.
There isn't even a single orientation.
And there's no up, there's no down.
There's no right or wrong way of holding it.
I don't have to change myself to fit the product, it fits me.